an eerie quiet and what are usually busy
streets and shops
president Gustavo Pedro ordered 2 500
people to leave the town of Marilla two
weeks ago over fears the nearby Novato
Del Ruiz volcano could erupt many
decided to stay
but tourists are staying away
people are afraid to come here we are
very affected we were waiting for Easter
which is a good season but he had major
losses because they closed everything
there is unemployment because people who
used to work in different places are out
of work
last month authorities issued an orange
Alert warning of a probable eruption in
the coming days or weeks
the Colombian geological Services has
since recorded an increase in seismic
activity and clouds of volcanic ash
many small business owners and Farmers
say they can't afford to leave
they have asked us to leave but our jobs
are here many people have a lot of work
with capital
local hotels restaurants and shops face
heavy losses those who already have
little say they have no choice
our life is worth more than an animal
and other things but as poor people we
have to go on it's not fair that we
leave our homes and our belongings
behind if the government supports us it
will be helpful but we can't lose our
things
for now people here say they have little
option but to wait
Al Jazeera